all right welcome back eli ah thank you
great to see you again
last time i spoke to you a few days ago
and you you told me you had not read the
comments on your video and i yeah and
then you did yeah dave showed me how to
do it and you're you're i was amazed
tell me tell me your reaction
whoo
a bunch of a bunch of it
why why would people even read something
like this
why would they care why would they give
a comment like they did
you know but i then i realized you know
there's still a lot of kind people out
there
a lot of people that give a damn
absolutely you know out here you run
into people that they don't care
and it takes something like what you're
doing
to make us realize well there is people
out there that really care
you know
skid row is a very kind of
it's a cr it's a very cruel little micro
it is it's cruel out here it's a very
small little part of the society that uh
right it's full of hustlers and snakes
and that's what they are i think if you
get out in the real world there are kind
compassionate people out there oh yeah
you know and you get stuck here in skid
row
that's where you're at you're stuck
and all you see is all all the evil
around you
you don't see what's really out in the
free world that
people care
yeah yeah
a lot of people felt you know their
hearts went out to you from that you
know after you told your story
it was amazing about your son committing
suicide and do you see that differently
now
because of this
because it almost sounded like you were
taking the blame for some of it or you
felt responsible i still do
i don't know if it's mainly because i
was a father
and i should have seen it
or what you know yeah i still take some
of the blame yeah you don't want to go
before your son or daughter does right
you know it's a lot of people
that answered
you know
they said
you know losing a child is just and it
is i i i lost my dad and all that i
didn't care you know i i cared i don't
mean it that way but it was nothing like
losing my son
no you know that was my heart
yeah but there must have been something
not right with him mentally to even do
that because he knew that he had people
like you that were going to be affected
by it right and as
i said mark
me and him sit down and talk just like
me and you are right now
and you would never in the world believe
that boy had problems we didn't see it
coming
he came over new year's had a few drinks
with us i was going to hang sheetrock
with him the next day and he was dead
you know it's just
that inability to explain why or how it
right if you left me a note
anything just to say this is why
you know
a lot of things were going wrong for him
and i i honestly think he just got tired
of life
that's what i really think he got tired
of life well being a cop is not easy no
no especially a deputy sheriff that's a
hard especially a deputy chef
you know and is that he was one of the
good cops if you had a point or two over
dui
man caused somebody to come get this car
in you right now if you got caught with
a little bit of dope
he would he'd pour it out and say don't
let him see you back out here tonight
he was one of the decent cops and a lot
of people didn't like him for it
you know
he would do anything for you
that
see this coming
no
no
we sat down new year's we both [ __ ]
for a while i had a few drinks
and he's not a drinker
he's yeah i'm gonna go ahead and go
homeless all right i'll see you in the
morning
yeah i seen him all right
your life's never been the same since
right no
no
um
that day i went and got about crown
royal
and you've never seen me without it in
my hand for two months
um when i had my my heart attack
i was in the hospital for about four
days
and i did a lot of thinking while i was
there
and i said to hell with life
and i went back to using drugs
i got a divorce from them
a female nobody would want to be married
to
and i came back out here
you know
had anti-issues life in the world
i could have stuck around stayed married
but not to what i was married to
she's a very very abusive lady
you wish
you know
you know it wasn't like your son
died in an auto accident it was like he
just unexplainably disappeared and it
was by his own doing right you know
why i don't know i i if he didn't let me
unknow
saying i'm sorry or i'll see you at the
end or anything just to tell me why he
did it
you know it's
just he didn't it'd be easier for you
yeah
you know how when you get a divorce you
tell your lady why yeah that's true
um sometimes
a lot of times i have horrible horrible
nightmares
i'll wake up in a coffin
i'll be at the gravesite talking to him
and he'll reach out to the grave and
tell me come on
it's all right down here
the dreams are scary
it takes me a few minutes to realize
where i am and everything else
a lot of times knowing i'm not nuts
i'll actually hear him calling my name
and it's his voice
no i'm not nuts and i'm not unknown
medication
i believe it's real
you know he keeps telling me it's okay
you know
i'm 65 and
only god knows how much time i'm going
to have here i can't do what he did
that's just
that's not the answer to it
talking about it
probably is a good start
you know everybody says go to a site
go to this first and go to that person
you know who's the best person talk to
you you
because you're not judgmental you've got
an open mind
you know psycho ain't gonna do nothing
forever put you on stupid dope
you know
it's good it's good to talk about
whatever you're going through
i wish i knew how to how to talk to him
did you did you ever talk to anybody
about this sir never never you're the
first person i've ever told anything to
oh wow
yeah the first one and you keep it
inside and carry it around every day
yeah
you know after after your last our last
interview i went around the corner and
got high
and it was like 15 20 pounds lifted off
my shoulders
you know i i've just never talked about
it
out here you don't talk to people
you know
it it it helped
i'm still trying to
figure out how much of this was my fault
for not not just not seeing it coming i
wouldn't say any of it you know
it's just
if i only knew why he did it
i i that i think that would put an end
to it that's a horrible thing to deal
with yeah
but i wouldn't i wouldn't take one
percent of the blame you know yeah if if
i could just find out why
you know i think that would help me a
lot
you know and when i die all i think is
am i gonna go see him
it's a horrible thing to live through
it's just hard
i miss him
ah
no parents should ever have to go
through that
you know you lose a parent a grandparent
a sister a brother you know
okay
you know but when when it comes down to
a child
somebody that you put your heart into
um
it's just
you put everything into it and you lose
it
well good to do you
you know i'd rather just stay the way i
am i love
that's just a word
you know
and everybody says the love comes in my
heart
it ain't just a heart it's your soul
it comes from your soul
and when it's taken away
this is hard
but staying here on skid row for the
rest of your life doesn't seem like the
the answer
no it's it's probably not mark i want to
go to san francisco that's where i want
to go
um i've been up there three or four
times the homeless community up in san
francisco is
is is a much
easier existence they gotta they got a
man that cares
i'm sorry no they got a mayor up there
that cares about the homeless
they've taken a couple fields and and
leveled them out and everything and you
can set your tent up there with no
questions
i know terrible things happen in any
every homeless community but yeah in
general you'll you'll have a much easier
time oh yeah because it's in the
tenderloin yeah you know and even the
cops are nice up there
you know so yeah i'm gonna i'm probably
gonna go back up if i were if i were
living homeless i'd figure out a way to
get up there that's what i'm gonna do
that's what i'm gonna do it's cold in
the winter but oh god is it oh god it's
cold up there aside from that it's it's
much nicer
i've survived this far
i can survive a little bit more
you know
this this down here
it don't get it no this is a really
very very treacherous little life life
here and you talk about hatred actually
bleeds into your mental state your
depression your
your it everything is it wears on you
yeah
you know
you got to watch behind your back
everywhere you go everything you do you
go to you go to buy something in a store
you gotta look around make sure nobody's
looking to see how much money you got
you know it's it's stupid here
it really is it's stupid it really is
yeah
that's a great way of describing
it well if you ever need a bus ticket to
get up to san francisco you let me know
okay i'll send you up there all right
with my blessing
i appreciate it and i'll come visit you
hopefully when i'm up there shooting
next time
i like i like to go up there and shoot i
would do it oh yeah i do it a lot yeah
oh okay all right all right it's a nice
break from skid row which is yeah a nice
break
yeah
you know i understand this is a doggy
dog world
but um
god don't kick you don't don't kick a
three-legged dog down
you know we ain't got nothing as it is
and then they want to rob you
that's just
yeah there's nothing but
snakes and hustlers
yeah and it just
it wears on me and i'm not even living
here i just come down for
to shoot and i leave and yeah lately
it's just really been hard for me just
to
deal with anything
at least with you
you know how to deal with us
you think yeah you know
you're you don't you don't belittle us
or anything like that and you listen to
us and that makes a big difference
a big difference yeah people are people
yeah
yeah
i still believe that
but sometimes i just get hustled so
badly
so often that it just it's hard to even
it's hard to deal
yeah i think san francisco would be a
good move yeah absolutely right so you
might get housing that that could that
could help you out right
well one step at a time and with the
housing mark you got to understand
something with me
i i was in the military i was cooped up
i was married i was cooped up i was a
truck driver for 21 years i was cooped
up
this here gives me the freedom
i don't have to worry about no rent no
lights no nothing
all i have to do is take care of myself
and look out for myself
is it a selfish way of looking at it
probably
you know because all your people out
there pay rent and all that they got car
payments and everything i don't and we
all think that it's the right way to
live but there's something i've been
down here so often done so many of these
talks that i see now there's something
primal right about the way that people
live here in in skid row and tenderloin
and a lot of other communities
they're living on the street right
they're free they're open they don't
have to pay the taxes they don't have to
go to work the next morning they do have
to figure out ways to feed themselves
and survive and get what they need but
there's something primal that's probably
more tuned into being human
than
than having your job and paying your
taxes and going to work in the morning
and doing all these things and listening
to a boss and all that kind of nice 90
of the homeless out here thinks people
owe them something
they don't own nothing
you know i don't i don't get food stamps
or anything yes i get myself scared i'm
65 years old
you know and that's what i live on
i don't ask these people for nothing
you know and everybody out there kind of
thinks well the homeless are getting
everything free in the world well maybe
they are but i'm not one of them
now i just look out for me
you know
but this this this place here is scary
yeah yes this
will make you think yeah you've been
here for two years yeah
yeah
it'll make you think
yeah it's probably time for you to get
out it is it's getting time
it's getting time
i hope you
somehow get past what happened with your
son or at least get a little bit more
past
what happened and and somehow see it
differently and maybe live
a life
i don't know it's better for something
better for eli you know yeah i'll never
get past it no you're not gonna get past
it but just be able to process it maybe
with all the comments everybody gave me
i can understand it
you know
he just he he broke my heart
he shattered my world
yeah
to love somebody screw that [ __ ]
uh-uh no
there ain't no such thing all that is
was hurt
you know i was married for 27 years
that thing i was married to
i quit loving her about 10 years after
we're married
i hate to ask this question but are you
would you couldn't consider yourself
happier at this point yes
living on the street homeless yeah as a
drug addict you're happier than you were
yeah
before all this wow you know i wake up i
get high when i go to bed or get high
you know
i don't do heroin or anything like that
i only do meth
and i don't shoot anymore i i was junkie
for a long time i got the scarves to
prove it you know
sticking that needle in the arm
ain't the way to do it smoke it
that needle is just it's addictive
it's a very addictive thing you know
screw a needle and i i smoke mess every
day
and it does what for you at this point
and for most people it it gives them
wakes them up gives them energy
yeah
sex drive stuff like that
what does it do to you
it doesn't put me in a depression
now if i go a couple days without doing
math
i'll sink into the right to the bottom
yeah but you need all your
brain chemistry to regulate after yeah
after you stopped using you have to stop
for for six months or a year probably to
stabilize so your body starts producing
what it is you know the people don't
needle exchange they've offered to give
me something to help me get off from it
but you know what
i'm not ready
you got to have it in your mind in your
heart to quit and i i don't have that
yeah that's more important yeah because
even if you force yourself to quit right
you still have the problems that are
behind
you know it's just
we're doing the math
things don't bother me so much
um
you got a lot of tweakers out there to
go through the dumpsters and all that i
don't do that crap yeah you don't seem
like a no you don't seem like an addict
no
you know and
it just puts me in a stage where i want
to be
i don't have to deal
with all the crap you know
it's just oh out there someplace now
when i come down yeah it's there
do i still have to deal with it yeah
we need to add a lighter pipe again
you
know yeah it'd be interesting to see
what what your experiences if you got up
to san francisco
yeah i'm going back up you know
i like it up there the tenderloin is a
nice place to be
you know and they're not so hard on you
up there no it's much more humane yes
yes even the cops up there say good
morning
you know
here
nobody cares
it's pretty clear that nobody cares
nobody cares nobody
you know what what gets me mark
every weekend saturday and sunday
all your holidays well there's so many
people out there giving away stuff and
feeding you
what about during the week
there ain't nothing
you know they put on a show here
you know
but i think the bay would do me a lot of
good
i do
yeah let me know if you ever want to go
up there okay we'll make that happen
all right all right eli thank you so
much for coming in again oh you're
welcome i wish you the best of luck
thanks love the hat
thank you
you